[Music]
in somebody's watching news somebody's
everyone started that different even
submitted by back to the present not to
the Future that's just right out mmm
Airbnb is battling privacy concerns as
guests are finding hidden cameras
planted in their rentals oh that's my
biggest fear what I would do it and I
have not to watch my tenants porn but I
want to make sure that nobody fail
nobody cares
well then just don't have anything that
you don't want filling but I like my
back wait am I allowed to have cameras
in the living room like a common area so
Airbnb says that as long as the host
okay where cameras are on their property
then it's fine but they are never
allowed in bathrooms or bedroom oh so if
you find a camera in the toilet you go
all a little mini jib arm and that
underneath the toilet so yeah I'm gonna
be a part of a pee compilation on a
[ __ ] porn site open mind would you
you Puritan I've heard about this some
lady she found like a camera in your air
B&B [ __ ] and that's why I'm about to do
I've always had a fear that there's
always new cameras yeah this one listen
now your Instagram is Instagram is right
it's probably worse than what the
cameras are going to find [ __ ] boring
but the cameras hidden camera with
someone else man you just sleep the
whole day sleeping these hidden cameras
in your house they're like on the front
and back of your phone at all times
that's what I'm that's what I'm scared
of dog left how we invite this [ __ ] in
our house and then we're like Alexa can
you listen to every [ __ ] single thing
I say and then sell me ads later in life
trust me watch when I was a kid I was
always afraid of like no I can't do that
there's cameras in the vent like I used
to be so scared for some reason that's
good you [ __ ] guilty little
Kachina yeah I remember doing meth and
thinking that
contacts captain okay got it
what's that contradictory flu yeah yes
what you were mentioning earlier there's
this it was it the 22 woman 22 year old
woman from Washington a motion-capture
thing oh that's a different one oh but I
was illegally recorded it's creepy yeah
so this is the first one I'm gonna tell
you guys about is this 22 year old from
Washington State they she went to
Switzerland just to learn Switzerland in
2016 with her friend when they
discovered a cell phone under the sink
in the bathroom somebody lost their
phone there they were recording someone
left it there how long as I should
record for no it was like life streaming
or something interesting they also found
an iPad that was also recording really
shitty couldn't you just steal their
[ __ ] I they get free iPad mmm true
and it's not no it's not plugged into
that yeah it better be like well where
did you have that yeah where was that
bad answer why was it you know I didn't
see it underneath the toilet in the
water picking it cuz he would have said
what was underneath the toilet facing
this if it's under the sink is there
just recording feet all day right maybe
he's a foot fetish guy taking a shower
and they get undressed and Oh depends on
how high I just I just pictured it at
though yeah okay okay I know where this
is that now it's like waist high I see
like a comb and [ __ ] like a brush yeah
yes so then they immediately left they
contacted Airbnb and so everyone be
refunded them for that trip and then
also other travel expenses that they
needed to have to go to a different
Airbnb so that was that and then the one
that you're talking about the motion
detector okay
oh the one they use for like dear hi we
are so sorry you found cameras in Europe
and your bear B&B and I mean here's a
coupon like were like what are you
what's that email what do you do
I know can you call the cops yeah we
just start masturbating in front of it
and that's what they want what they want
Oh fake like a murder scene it just
freak him out [ __ ] freaking out mmm
yeah so this one they tweeted out and oh
that's the thing now news a colleague of
mine thought it thought it odd there was
a single motion detector in his air BnB
in the bedroom and voila it's an IP
camera connected to the web he left at
3:00 a.m. reported post a suspended
collie got refund so yeah this is like
one of the hidden cameras that they
found and they also report that there
was this other homeowner who who did the
same they put cameras where they
shouldn't be putting him and so the
homeowner was arrested for video boyar
job yeah so this is apparently is this a
thing now you gotta be careful damn I
stayed airing these all the time yeah
they suggest like if you want to protect
yourself you can invest in a digital
device detector oh what's that
I know I googled it right after I said
James Bond [ __ ] on yeah so it's pretty
much like you know the movies and they
had like a bug detector that wrote it is
like oh there's different kind for those
doing some research too because this is
always my biggest fear too and so that's
the biggest fear I know like mine boobs
feels like a teen stored mechanical
spider yeah like their biggest fear you
know what you got a point there is being
recorded yeah these [ __ ] like sounds
like a Tyrannosaurus Rex [ __ ] scary
mmm some reason are you guys why is this
so scary for girls to be recorded I
never get it cuz I will be at home and
then like the minute it starts getting a
slightly dark she swears there's 20
telescopes peeking into our bedroom
suggestive clothes yeah but I don't know
why it comes to nudity and equipment or
more vulnerable and like if you like
Nicki doesn't give one [ __ ] I always
draw on the blinds up and I'm like yo
you're like topless right now what the
[ __ ] I'm like I'm doing that [ __ ] so
what are you doing it for then he might
understand yeah what am i doing why am i
doing that because okay because it's a
fishbowl at night like if you have your
lights on and it's dark no one can see
them
on the geographical area that you're in
think once again star gets [ __ ] dark
if someone's on the sidewalk you're just
gonna look like a silhouette they're not
gonna see titties you're not gonna see
her if it's dark
yeah outside and inside it's illuminated
you're completely wrong Nazi titties I'm
seeing titties you know saying so it's
not like in in art and are only one of
those like peepers outside of their home
like it's night outside it's data early
they have the lights on inside and the
heat all trying to spy on his neighbors
boys Colorama you know how many homes I
brought like I know this [ __ ] from that
distance
no one's gonna [ __ ] see you how many
homes have you wrote I don't remember a
lot that wasn't in a in our room that's
an accomplished in our room I'm afraid
of the people in the backyard you could
totally see you right
yeah dude you're not afraid I was at
your house your window was wide open you
were just topless and I'm like Rogers
like dude your neighbors could see you
topless wear it in the front or in the
back
you're the bedroom I was with you in the
room I'm sorry stops changing ocean
you're just saw like pity that I'm like
dude your name I always wonder like oh
yeah we had sex all the time we were
like we hope somebody record this well
Willa you know because I know that the
neighbor in the back is like it's just a
hill right I know what table would rent
the house yeah oh now you have bad
neighbors look I don't want these no one
cares
they don't deserve the Peep Show right
right yeah yeah these digital device
detective things apparently they're like
different kind so one of them it's like
for wired kind of camera I don't know a
lot of tech stuff involved in it but
then there's this other one where I like
that this other one no that can do it
all and I was like ugh looking at that
one is like 150 oh that's pretty cool
when you buy a package of something it's
like it's like got the latest technology
with an exclamation point for people
like - if we're like it's got latest
texture
yeah it's infection no I mean when I was
reading it it made sense but I can't
regurgitate it I'm gonna do it
I'll [ __ ] check the room everywhere I
go
yeah they're also saying you can just
use a flashlight and try to spot lenses
cuz that bad that detector thing that I
looked at that was 150 all it does is
just shine red light that's [ __ ]
funny
so I shine his red light right and you
look through it like this little
viewfinder and that has like a red film
on it so you could see so if there's a
lens it would just show like a wall so
it doesn't even detect like electrical
signal no one is just for the lenses but
they have other ones though that can
they can detect signals yeah I would
hire a 500-pound man to go in the house
before me and use the restroom in the
shower yeah before we even set foot in
there yep and that way they're turning
off everything oh that's why they're
unplugging [ __ ] from the wall that guy
yeah that's way less likely no good then
they want to see more being a youtuber I
think what I want to do is make sure
that if there is a camera I could give
the best performance possible so your
dude so true yeah
I know I would try to drink more water
so it could be longer yeah take some
yeah I feel self-conscious like you know
you know sometimes you have those
trickle Peas you just think you had to
pee but then you're not sure and you do
the trickle pee I normally have a
stronger stream yeah I don't know what's
happening talking to the camera and the
toilet dude I'm so sorry I can do better
like I can see the light and we make
that a mistake like can we do one more
please I'll come back I'm just gonna
drink this gallon of water you know like
oh dude usually I take way bigger shits
like honestly like you know I just shat
before it came here it'll be awesome
it's gonna come out no but it's like all
over the world cuz they're even saying
that those is German tourists back in
June those German tourists well they
were at a California air B&B
poorni California there's a show on
Netflix right now it's this guy that
rigged his whole motel thing with like a
like on his rooftop he could spy on them
and if he wrote all these notes of
people [ __ ] and all that and that
actually became data or sexual he was a
peep
with his wife too but the peeping tom
paid off yeah because it I don't know if
it helped out for sexual psychology or
whatever but be back then there was no
data on that stuff and it was so taboo
right so no one knew they witness a
murder is yes and he couldn't you
couldn't report it cuz you don't want
anyone to know about his like little
secret see this is like amateur porn to
me I'm like there's no production value
it doesn't look good you love that no
saying I like it to look professional
I've amateur bored yeah I never
understood people boy is only yes boy I
like it you like that yeah sometimes I
look for specifically hacked it was like
a thing of mine in college like hacked
upskirt videos look hacked no no not
those those are boring but like hacked
like videos that they made for the
boyfriend or something like that or like
a couple video like to revenge porn and
[ __ ] yeah those were awesome
[Music]